convivial et solidaire deux mots qui
définissent plaisir selon la fédération
européenne des solidarités de proximité
son président atanase périfan a
récompensé la ville pour ses actions qui
favorisent le lien social
on en fait un ratio d'associations un
plaisir pour une ville de 30 mille
habitants qui au niveau européen et le
même ratio qu'une vigne de 100000
habitants fer qui a autant
d'associations à plaisir que dans une
ville européenne qui est trois fois plus
nombreuses le travail qui est fait en
termes par le service social
le projet ville solidarité qui a été
développé par exemple est assez
emblématique des mois de travail qui ont
été réalisés pour interroger les
habitants pour les rencontrer ce projet
ville solidarité lancée en 2014 prévoit
la mise en place de transports adaptés
pour les seniors un forum du handicap et
la lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
le festival escales d'ailleurs qui met à
l'honneur les différentes cultures de la
ville où les fresques du vally boues
sont eux aussi des exemples du bien
vivre ensemble des événements qui ont
permis à la ville de recevoir ce label
c'est vrai que d'obtenir à label
européen en plus de la part de la nasse
périph ans c'est vrai que c'est une
vraie reconnaissance mais ce qui est
important c'est tout ce qu'on a été dur
on a fait et tout ce qui nous reste à
faire parce qu'il reste beaucoup de
choses à faire
donc on est fiers oui c'est un bon
moment avec cette distinction plaisir se
hisse parmi les villes les plus
conviviales d'europe auprès de lisbonne
prague et du blanc